no no you're using it wrong what it's
not Cologne I noticed this this is what
black people don't even know they exist
but I even think that we don't burn but
we do you miss completely you need some
on your legs so your [ __ ] is a she
this is tea time with me hastens trail I
know some people are like excellent
question what is he wearing and I'm
wearing the golf outfit of a street
[ __ ]
look at that alright so what do you say
we go ahead a couple balls and warm up
before we get out there
pause pause and we need to be clear on
how we describe what we're doing okay
we're now gonna get a couple balls let's
go hit some golf balls but at this range
in this house there's some holes in this
Cup
now do you do you play golf gang gang
look at that the marathon can Tim the
marathon continues good pin it all right
Pete Nipsey Hussle let's go let's do it
how far do you hit your pitching wedge
about 25 millimetres towards the 25th
section of that sounds about right yeah
go for yeah that sounds about right
not bad that was better than I thought
he was gonna hit was better than you
thought I was no no I don't know I mean
there it is there it is y'all I'm tell
you what is y'all want from me Brooke
that's pretty good I don't see just
can't poke clubs like that out here a
hundred dollars to hit the tree it hit
the tree hit the tree is it that you
going you want to bet a hundred dollars
I hit that tree again
do I want to bid $100 I hit the tree
good what do I look like son I got brown
went to a strip club last night man so I
got a lot of singles why your one dollar
bill ashy because I was in there with
some Ashley hoes I don't just expect my
dad like I'll try to throw me off
alright that was a good practice right
you ready to go hit the green if you
already know this just try to stay
focused okay my bad my bad
a lot of people in this cough cause
looking like I feel the greens wrong and
they're absolutely right
you're disrespecting me man no no no you
need your golf bag man thank you yes sir
and this just went oh oh oh all right yo
man did you just hit me brah no no no
not at all
son you don't tell me put my seatbelt or
nothing you don't give a [ __ ] about me
man no no no there's no seat better than
golf course why we can't do a show like
this is about rope rollin blunts and
[ __ ] something up my alley bro do you
want me to tell first or you go first
you want to show I know it's your
[ __ ] show no I'm not okay yeah yeah
go for it Dawg left left man [ __ ] all
that man I'm gonna hit the ball that's
what we say the streets well guys you
know I don't really know how to play
either right man whatever you did this
part I just want to do that [ __ ] great
Oh with the little draw you saw that yo
y'all see people in my mind's telling me
no [ __ ] show off man I smoked that
[ __ ] son when people send their mojo
they're always one shade darker than
what they really are just want to be
more powerful like I don't care this I
should just when you want to emphasize
anything always use the black fish they
don't matter your age it emphasizes
there you go oh and you miss a trap that
was a close I didn't think I was gonna
get that close huh that's pretty good
I'm just trying to make it easy for you
bro thank you I appreciate it I don't
know we hang this is your show I thought
we couldn't come off to you oh yeah
you're right
goddamn son you brought to get us
arrested they got sensors
Donelle oh oh you take power now come on
let's go same Club easy-peasy
yep Oh money right through the trees
I'm about to go hit my shot right quick
man give a [ __ ] about your shots but
I'll meet you on the green I'm on the
green hey diddle-diddle right down the
middle of the grid is when somebody says
I'll see you already come on with all
these golf terms man I need to stay over
here right yeah you got to hit the ball
on the green by the language I've got a
do man oh okay I'll just answer your
question you didn't gotta say you gotta
hit the ball you play golf with balls
right right my man I'm redundant my bag
on now my bad
I'm on a grave this shot works out in
the fan are you calling a [ __ ] I just
try to freak out with you that's what we
try to figure out why are you got no
goddamn what's the [ __ ] to caddy
because it's a low-budget show galleys
[ __ ] bro I can't believe I'm gonna
goddamn green stop that's not bad
[ __ ] nice out hey soos oh wow I
burnt it that went right over the hole
no break they're running fast are you
over here
I know could you stop disrespecting me
bro that's all I'm actors I've ever
loved there I'm gonna start doing jokes
about your beard and how nervous I am
what about my beard I just know it you
start counting backwards this whole golf
course would be [ __ ] empty
hahahaha let's get real right now
let's get real
nice that's a 30-foot putt right there
holy cow and stop playing with me out
here that's what I'm saying
that's all I'm saying so what was it
again hello 30-foot putt did duck is
that what I heard thirty foot foot
that's all upstairs I stopped playing
with me I quit oh and that was not
interested
[Music]
so I saw a picture of you and Bill
Murray and South Carolina what was that
like it was incredible because you hear
the term people saying a goat and a
legend Bill Murray is like a a comedic
legend nothing he hasn't done on the
funny side of dramatic side yeah
but hanging out with him it's like for
me I'm macho it is like stripes and all
I wanted to say was lighten up Francis
lighten up Francis but he was a cool guy
and a couple of people were taking pizza
with him and I always try think outside
the box I said what if I can get Bill
Murray to do the wu-tang sign and he I
did not think he would do it but he
through the woods and he had a little
gangster face when he did he was like
whoo tang did you walk him no I had a
short do it I had to show her yeah but
it's simple like for me in the kilted
Yanis so mad at me yo De Aza mad at me
you should why look at him chilling now
no no season beautiful hit me three
times [ __ ] oh dang it I did one of
those Donnell shots with the grass out
can we focus on your [ __ ] don't you say
why does it always come back to games
coming through
meet me on whoa
[Applause]
switch
oh so you just started the Parkinson
your first part guys you never really
done that game I was nervous about it
because I one thing about Parkers I feel
like you always asking people if they
want to be on the show right I did Joe
Rogan podcast maybe a year ago and I'm
he pushes everybody probably do a
podcast but he was really really serious
about me doing it and I was a little
nervous
he finally took a stab at it and I'm at
my eleventh episode the downturn rollin
shows streaming on all platforms to done
at rollin show check it out it's like
I'm new to it so I'm finding my voice
I'm finding my style but at the same
time I'm just having so much fun doing
yeah make sure you check out the Darnell
Ross holy [ __ ] you read the comment you
know what roben told me Darnell if you
want to have a copy
don't read the calmness and what is the
first thing you did read every genius
gold legend yeah then you start getting
those people like [ __ ] how can I get
that time of my life back and show just
so handsome now they tell you the time
Cole I give I almost shot myself in 138
yeah yo I wanted to die three deaths at
2014 you know on a timeline what's the
worst comment you read on there the
worst comment I've read was corny ass
[ __ ]
and I wasn't fitting by the n-word I was
offended by the c-word and in comedy
corny corny in word I've never been
corny you could be mad at me you could
disagree with something of a corny that
has a disgusting word when you say I'm
corny basically you're saying you [ __ ]
my girlfriend in high school and I never
got over that that's what that means
you're upset about something
well let's do it let's uh [ __ ] my
girlfriend an [ __ ]
nice bro yo that's the shot for your ass
brah uh-huh
it's gonna get the eventually nothing
wrong with that you're a - I'll give you
a ride
I want to ride with you I'm good bro I
don't need a ride you're gonna need a
ride I'm so good I did it my way but
much much more than that
I did it my way I bit it up I spit it
out Sammy did ice and spit it out
I did it dry way we're gonna do it up
again the bottle bro hot porn that's
called popcorn golf pap-pap you a
show-off
dan that's out Jesus it's downhill dang
it
and the winner is Donnell Rawlings don't
move aside yeah you didn't know one
thanks for coming out man
what I never won anything I want to
thank my mother my father I want to
thank my mom my father more importantly
god I want to thank my son I want to
thank all the chicks had never [ __ ] me
in high school you want to [ __ ] me now
it's too late [ __ ] you oh and make sure
you check out the down there Rawlings
show is streaming on all platforms just
check them out on Netflix Showtime
yes Netflix the shelter I'm just I'm
just so excited thank you for all the
white people who supported my career all
these years
it's two of them maybe more but just
thank you just thank you thank you I did
it
Golf rules everything around me but I do
want to apologize for what beating the
[ __ ] out of you in golf today beginner's
luck in his goddamn [ __ ]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]